el gobierno del presidente Joe biden se
ha mostrado resistente a tomar la
decisión de designarlos como terroristas
a estas organizaciones A qué se debe
esto
y bueno no es cualquier decisión
evidentemente no lo lleva totalmente
otro nivel este tipo de organizaciones y
las herramientas con las que cuentan
ambos estados para combatirlos pero más
allá de eso y lo que yo diría es que lo
preocupante en este caso es que México
no está haciendo su parte en combatir
estas organizaciones en específico este
gobierno el gobierno del presidente
López Obrador y eso está generando
tensiones con Estados Unidos nuestras
economías nuestras vidas están cada vez
más integradas entre Estados Unidos y
México y si no nosotros nos ponemos las
pilas en nuestro país en poner órdenes
nuestro territorio pueden pasar más
cosas como las de Matamoros están
llegando inversiones están llegando a
vivir esta estadounidenses a México y si
le siguen pasando tragedias como la de
Matamoros estas tensiones van a crecer
más y más me parece que la colaboración
entre ambos países es la clave porque es
un problema binacional Y si me lo
permites es un problema internacional el
del crimen organizado ahora qué tal
significativa para la seguridad Nacional
de Estados Unidos sería declarar a estos
carteles de la droga como terroristas
que cambiaría por ejemplo mira
francamente creo que se trata más de un
asunto político y creo que proviene de
del ambiente pues ya preelectoral de
Estados Unidos y también el mexicano y
me parece que es más de una postura Pues
de los conservadores en Estados Unidos
de decir hagamos más y el gobierno
actual del presidente no está haciendo
lo suficiente para obligar a México a
hacer su parte realmente podría haber
algunos beneficios sobre todo en materia
de combate digamos al financiamiento de
estas organizaciones se la pensarían dos
veces las las organizaciones
estadounidenses que colaboran con los
carteles de las drogas